seize lever de soleil le documentaire du
réalisateur pierre emmanuel le goff
revient sur l'épopée spatiale de thomas
pesquet six mois pendant lesquels le
spationaute est devenu le vrp de
l'espace au travers des réseaux sociaux
pesqué partager quotidiennement les
photos et vidéos de son aventure avec
une volonté faire vivre son expérience
un souhait que d'autres hommes de
l'espace avait aussi avant leur en 1968
derrière le hublot de sa cabine la
mairie tard frank baumann raconter son
expérience en direct une première
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
comment ce que nous recevons un an plus
tard lors de la légendaire mission
apollo 11 neil amstrong comme entête en
direct ses premiers pas sur la lune avec
cette phrase inoubli depuis les premiers
départs dans l'espace les agences
spatiales favorise cette mise en scène
des astronautes en 1987 grâce à la
vidéotransmission les soviétiques la
veine kiné romanenko auprès d'une visite
de la station mir
alors vous vous été en notre phonothèque
notre bibliothèque de cassettes vidéo
nous passons la partie centrale qui est
notre salon les communications inter
spatiale dépasse aussi le cadre
scientifique ou télévisuelle en 1999
une cinquantaine d'enfants dialoguer
avec le spationaute michel tonini en
direct de la navette américaine columbia
leur préoccupation était au bout du
compte ce traité
son joli qu'avez vous mangez sera ta vie
avez-vous bien dormi
[Musique]
en 1996 claudie haigneré était la
première femme française à se rendre
dans l'espace pendant ces 16 jours
passés à bord de la station mir
elle échangera souvent avec les
journalistes de retour sur terre la
spationaute continuera de partager son
aventure elle évoquait sa frustration à
ne pas pouvoir tout montrer aux
téléspectateurs
moi j'ai dans les yeux des images
extraordinaires les couleurs des reflets
lumière que j'ai pas pu lui traduire
avec la caméra
je n'ai plus très bien avec l'appareil
photo j'essaie de vous ramener un
maximum de choses mais des choses qu'on
ne peut pas montrer grâce aux évolutions
nos logiques et aux réseaux sociaux
thomas pesquet nuit aura réussi à tout
montrer en direct pour notre plus grand
bonheur
[Musique]